okay i think we're ready to get down to
differentiator right now now
um don't fret too much this will be much
quicker than before okay remember there
are three parts
to the continuity definition right there
are also three parts for
differentiability
but it's uh
f dash x for each one
just have a look at your definition in
the three parts for continuity
and it's saying f of x is this and f of
c is that
the limit of f going this way and f
going that way is the same
for something being differentiable it's
all of that but for the derivative
this is the graph instead okay so
what would it mean what does that mean
well usually we'll think about this way
i'll give you two examples
if something is not continuous okay
then it certainly cannot be
differentiable
okay because there's breaks in the
function itself
so that means there must be breaks in
the derivative too okay
but there are functions that are
continuous
and they may or may not be
differentiable
okay is differentiable
is not differentiable
okay so most of the ones that you've
been dealing with so far
come under this heading okay the
function's continuous it's you know
like y equals x squared minus five x
plus six something simple like that
okay that's continuous there are no
holes in it you differentiate it
and you get this which also has no holes
in it so
everything's happy okay but there are
some important examples you need to get
where it starts off nice but then when
you differentiate you get problems
okay so let's start with one you're
really familiar with
the absolute value of x absolute value
of x
now i'll admit this is a bit sleeky
because really it's not one function but
two
okay but let's think about what's
happening here
um i'm not going to answer the question
of like differentiating it yet i just
want to look at it
okay so this is what the graph looks
like
okay now it's a continuous function
because number one there are no breaks
number two i can draw the whole thing
in fact i did draw the whole thing
without lifting my pen okay and you can
think about the limit as
x approaches zero from this side and as
it approaches this side
everything's fine okay but then when you
think about the gradient
something's wrong okay so for instance
as i approach uh the origin
okay what's the gradient doing on this
side what is the gradient
of any point on this branch it's it's
one
right gradient one one one one
one so if i took the limit
as x approaches zero from the positive
side
okay the derivative the gradient f
dash would be one because what look at
it it's like one one one one it's
approaching one
okay but when you take the limit from
the other side
okay you can clearly see the different
kind of behavior it's a decreasing
function over here
it's minus one minus one minus one minus
one
all the way up to i'm not including the
origin
okay so seeing as
the derivative therefore can't be
defined at the origin
so we say y equals the absolute value of
x
is not differentiable
at this particular point that we're
interested in
okay and that's a really important idea
to get across okay
it's continuous there but it's not
differentiable though
all right now let me give you yeah
question um
it's not as it's not as bad as x squared
on x
which has a discontinuity
yes okay now i just want to give you one
more counter example
again a continuous function that isn't
differentiable at a particular point
um that is and i want you to have a go
wrapping it first before i show it to
you
maybe you're familiar with this shape um
i'd like you to graph this
what does this guy look like
cube root of x that's x to the power of
the third
you could plot points that would not be
that bad an approach
or you could think of it in terms of you
know we've been thinking about functions
and relations that kind of thing
i can redefine this as i can cube both
sides
cubing both sides is not as bad as
squaring both sides because
these two are equivalent i haven't
gotten rid of negative solutions by
cubing both sides okay now what would
this look like
well you guys know what y equals x cubed
looks like so what would happen
if you swapped it would just go sideways
right so
one side looks like this
uh it's sort of like x sorry it's sort
of like the square root of x
but um it goes shallower and faster just
like x cubed goes steeper
faster right it's an investment what is
the other side of the plate
it's um it's an odd function right it
has
odd symmetry okay so there's
the cube root of x now you can see
this ticks all the boxes for continuity
does it not
it's defined at all points and it's uh
if you take the limit at any two places
if you go from both sides you'll get the
same value
everything's but then you differentiate
so d y on dx
now i rewrote this in index form because
it's a little easier to deal with
because this is just power rule right so
what do i get when i differentiate
bring the power out the front and then
you reduce the power by one
which gives you a third minus one which
is minus two over three
okay now let's just rearrange this a
little bit
that's a negative power right so it's
one over three x
okay so now can you see why there are
problems creeping in
because this derivative doesn't exist at
a particular point namely
x equals zero
okay now why is that
so if i were to draw a tangent there
right well actually i already have drawn
the tangent because the tangent
at the origin is the y-axis right and of
course a vertical line
doesn't have a gradient because gradient
needs run it needs horizontal movement
horizontal change
and a vertical line doesn't have any
horizontal change it's just
there on a single point so therefore we
say just like with the absolute value of
x
it's continuous but not differentiable
at x equals zero
okay and this um this particular example
q rex will come up again later
when we look at graphing it's this weird
graph that's always got problems with it
okay so we'll come back to it again